all right Joshua yes Joshua where's your
girl where are you from I grew up on
3700 block of Michigan in South St Louis
Missouri
and tell me about your family
my mom is a opiate
um meth Coke addict my dad is the first
leader of the Aaron Brotherhood chapter
of St Louis
and for St Louis and
um Farmington
which is
Saint Francis County
um
my dad has 20 kids
my mom has three
my grandparents
raised me you know about
10 years then my dad's half black son
their family adopted me because I was
being neglect and abused so
you know so your dad is the the head of
the Aryan Brotherhood yes first Chief
but he has a half black son
yeah because he uh raped a black woman
and
and yeah
that's because uh
they don't like black people and that's
was the
repercussion of some black man did
something to somebody and that's what
they chose to do
and it's [ __ ] up
he spent two years in prison for it
how would you describe your childhood
um
when I was growing up like when I was an
infant my dad uh was had a meth lab and
I was living with him my dad and my mom
my dad had a meth lab and anhydrous meth
lab
and um I got fed like maybe once a week
by them and so I was like uh whenever I
was three months I was
16 pounds
now it's supposed to be like
25 or 30 or something around there
and so my family would come over and see
a
McDonald's like three McDonald's fries
on the tray they've been there moldy for
a week that I was eating
and my my dad would if I didn't eat fast
enough would take my food away which has
grown into for my entire life so far
when I eat I eat in less than five
minutes anything I have a full plate of
food stacked less than five minutes is
gone
because I feel like my food's gonna be
taken away and it's just stuck in my
head is imprinted
and then
um
my grandparents they they absolutely
hated me they said that I was a problem
child
[Music]
and they threatened to take me to the uh
orphanage
and whether or not because my dad
whenever I was
six months old seven months old around
there
um hit his meth lab got busted in and he
shot the cop in the head with a shotgun
and
now he's heard uh
20 or 20 years and he got out when I was
20 years old
and when he got out
he still the biggest [ __ ] in the
world
and
um told me that you know he loves me
but he he can't [ __ ] with me
but he'll he'll protect me and help me
whoever I need but he can't [ __ ] with me
so I've only hung out with my dad
probably like six times in my entire
life yeah so he was in prison for most
of your childhood all my childhood
who took you to school or did stuff like
that uh the Aryan Brotherhood member
said he would send or take me to school
dropping off
if I got because I got bullied a lot
because you know I had separation issues
from
not having a mom not having a dad my mom
was in prison my dad was in prison
my mom was hanging out
um
my mom
prostituted whatever she could do to me
where her money sugar daddies
my
my dad you know the only thing I ever
got from him throughout my whole
childhood while he was locked up
was in Nintendo 64 Pikachu edition I
remember like he got he got him Donkey
Kong
in a 25 Aaron brotherhoods members came
over to give it to me and then they sat
outside at my grandparents without their
permission getting total leave
uh singing Christmas carols
so you see a bunch of girl names
carols outside my grandparents
and that was not not my grandparents
style but it was funny what are the
Aryan Brotherhood numbers kind of get
into where is it what do they do
um they they are the largest producers
of methamphetamine in the United States
and
um
like all the routes you know Route 66
being the biggest trade route
you know St Louis
is not where the mess is made as people
like to believe it is it's what we call
Jefferson County
which is Arnold Fenton
um Hillsboro which is a country because
you know country farmland
and they make
like when I pulled up Frieza with my dad
of crystal meth
um
we pull out one freezer was 400 pounds
Crystal and then that made my dad 2.2
million dollars usually like one freezer
but about 2.2
and
he still
um how should I say this
um allegedly he does it today
so where is your adult life taking you
um I met my wife when I was 22.
her name's uh Kate
she's
she has her her issues as well like you
know she got molested by her dad
and stuff like that so she has you know
issues with men
and my dad and my mom and my
grandparents didn't like her my Dad
tried to have her killed and whatever
and I like try to prevent that and so I
you know
was
I served my wife was I'm fitting off for
six years at the time I had never did
fetty
I only did Crystal
and
um
uh I drove her to go pick it up one
night
and then we got T-Bone by a police
officer which you guys coming up on the
news
is
um
a blown I blew a light
the light was yellow I was trying to get
past it I had
my dad had bought me an 01 Ford F-150 uh
Harley-Davidson edition it's a spoiler
the hood scoop supercharged
and I thought my truck is fast enough
and
um the police officer that was driving
was going 80 miles an hour and hit us on
my side we rolled seven times I broke
all my ribs as can be seen for all going
inwards
instead of being you know normal place
would be out about there they're all
inwards
and they're all they all move they all
can dislocate
and then you know they got broken out
here when I hit the steel pole
and I got stabbed out here so
I've been shot twice been shot right
here and I've been shot in the back of
my head
and then but the back to the car
accident
I I never been knocked out nobody's ever
been man enough to knock me out of the
way I like to put it but during the car
accident the only reason my wife
survived it was like I grabbed her by
her hair and pulled her to me
because the way that she was going was
the car hit from my side so I had to
drink this way and her window hit the
concrete first so I would have slammed
her head into the concrete because she
wasn't wearing her seat belt and I was
not either
and my gun uh flew and hit her and the
head and knocked her out and went out
the window
I had a tourist uh a G3 millennium
and it laid her ass out
I felt bad but that's probably also what
saved her from being freaked out
it knocked it hit us so hard and knocked
her shoes off her feet
yeah then I started using fentanyl
because the hospital because I did
Crystal wouldn't give me no opiates
and I laid in the floor crying for three
days before I told my wife the
you get a syringe and fill it up and
never use needles
and they hit me with it so that I could
feel better
see the only thing that took away the
pain
and it still is
ever since
I I quit when I came out here I came out
here first before my wife for two months
I came out here August 28th and she came
out here October 9th
and
I got offsetting
but then somebody snuck up behind me and
re-broke my ribs with a steel pole
and because they thought I was trying to
get with their woman I am loyal to my
wife I've never seen it ever
you know you know I can't say the same
for her
but I forgive her she's you know she has
her issues
Nobody's Perfect
and you know
it is what it is
you can't you can't dwell on somebody's
mistakes you guys dwell on what makes
them who they are as an individual
and her as an individual is
she's the sweetest most beautiful
kindness woman I've ever met like
right now she's she's mad at me but
she
she still watching that and I slept on
her lap she sat up and let me sleep on
her lap so I had a cushion last night
because I can't I hadn't slept for two
days
and she rode my head so I fell asleep
and she stayed awake to watch her stuff
and
I can't I I really can't thank her
enough for everything she has done for
me because she has you know when we
didn't have money for dope she's
prosecuted herself
was
that hurts
because I should be able to support her
but
hopefully things will get better
where are you guys staying now
on the streets
by MacArthur Park
that's the only place we
we
got
sorry about that bro
we had a place when we first got here
with one of my GD
gang members
and he lost his place because he wasn't
here to stay there
and you know we try to leave us down the
street so many times and he said
they kicked me out they kicked me out
but he's like until I'm out you guys
aren't out
and
it's been rough but
um we're trying to make it through it
I'm a certified auto mechanic
I wouldn't you know schooling
and
I just
I just I moved to LA
for fresh start to get my me and my lady
away from all the drama and [ __ ]
we weren't homeless in St Louis
but
my family didn't like her
and
it you know
we
came out here had a place to stay that
got shot down
she has a felony warrant
in Illinois and they won't extradite her
from here
so that's why we can't go back
because
if she goes to prison
I don't know what I would do
gosh that's my best friend that's my
everything
like I would die before I would take a
position before
and
I don't know I just
if one thing I tell everybody is
you guys taste stronger
than than the other people around you
because nobody is going to be your
support except for your significant
other
and I have [ __ ] up and me and I have
gotten into fights
and
I've sadly like
you know I pulled her hair I respect her
and I regret it it hurts
it bothers me I've done it
and I apologize to her consistently
because she didn't deserve that
regardless she uh she hit me first but
I'm a grown ass man I should be able to
step away
but L.A
will tear your relationships apart
so you and anybody comes out here
meeting you and your stuff together
you guys are who you got
well people are going to try to tear you
all apart
don't believe it they're lying to you
any more questions buddy do you have any
friends
you don't have any friends other than
your wife do you have any friends
the one um
uh what's his name um
I'm battling names
uh Billy
you're one of your people
he's he's not he's in corporeal
acquaintance and friends still
but he's been good to me and
not really my only friends but my wife
she's the only one that has my back and
that's what my friend is
somebody who takes care of you and
watches your back make sure you don't
get
[ __ ] over
or make sure that you're not upset or
sad
and I hope that
me and her
last forever because when she when she
if she ever refuses you know with me
I'm not gonna I don't think I'm gonna
live much longer after that
because she's
everything to me is that your biggest
fear
it's my only
I'm not scared of anything buddy not
scared of God
I'm scared of losing her
your chaotic childhood
is that what you'd point a finger at for
all the crazy twists and turns your life
has taken
I can't say that because we all have
free will
it definitely it definitely influenced
it it definitely put a strain
it definitely
it brings it makes me more aggressive
and like
it it takes a toll not having a dad for
most of my life and then him popping and
basically
turned to where you do this you do this
and you have to do it because you you
know the first time I told him no
uh he he broke my nose and
uh shattered my teeth
that's from that's awesome brothers
that's my dad
and he told me to suck it up buttercup
and so I did
you feel like life is unfair
life isn't supposed to be a thing
I think everybody should have equal
chance so
I don't wish the parents being gang
members or anybody
nobody
I'm a gang member myself
but my my gang as a Gangster Disciple
we loyalty love respect wisdom knowledge
those are the main
the main traits and understanding
like
we don't
believe in hurting children or hurting
your children or you heard this process
well me me putting my hands on my wife
yes that's against our code
I I shouldn't have done that and I that
I do blame it the fact that my my mom as
I grew up it hurt me in and out
my mom's treated me like [ __ ] like beat
me whatever she could like when I was 11
she uh she spanked me so hard she broke
her arm
and then she told the hospital that I I
broke her arm like by jumping on it
so in
I had to spend time with UV
for that and I didn't I didn't do
anything
so life being fair
it ain't gonna be fair
but
everybody does have an opportunity
to change their situation
I've lost my ID and everything and so
you know I have to get that back
I owe money to
people for some I didn't do so that you
know that shows how Fairless is
how has your life changed when you were
addicted to Crystal Meth as opposed to
now when you're addicted to fentanyl
when I'm on crystal I work every single
day
I was a first assistant manager at
Circle K
hours over 80 hours a week
I I had nice fat paychecks
I ordered Xanax on dark web
and I sold them I made 10 grand every
three days
ten thousand bars to come in I'd make
another 10 grand three days
and I ordered them with my paychecks
and
so anybody had any more motivated
when I got fitting off
my motivation is high
but my drive to actually get it
completed
isn't there anymore my my perfectionism
isn't there anymore
my life isn't there anymore
Everything's changed
it's your biggest regret
putting my hands in my life
as as my only regret
I love going to her like I should
Joshua what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
total
don't do drugs
they are not worth it and they never
will be
if somebody offers it to you
am I saying ghost instrumental please
don't don't do that
just say no
there's no reason to do it or no reason
anybody needs to do it
if your parents are gang members
try to get to a different
see if you can live with a family member
get yourself out of that predicament
because
after I got shot twice I've been stabbed
it's not fun
I ran around with assault rifles in St
Louis and shot at cars and shot police
and
never got caught
and
you know no there's no proof of who did
it
but
is it
is it really a good thing no is it fun
no
the whole Thrill is the part of getting
caught
why do you want to go to prison for life
for a joy ride with a gun
you know
all right Joshua thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome man
wish you lots of luck out here
thanks thank you